عندما يتعلق الأمر بالعثور على مساحة في مقدمة مقصورة شركة الطيران ، فهي سوق مزدحمة للغاية وفي هذا العصر الحديث للطيران لا توجد طرق كثيرة للتميز ، لذا فقد راهن رئيس الأرياف على درجة الأعمال بدلاً من المقعد الذي يتكئ أنه يعرض شخصًا لا يتعمد مع التحذيرات ، يمكنك أن تعرف أن تجعل نفسك مرتاحًا في وضع الجلوس عندما تحصل على راحة ساق الذراع ، ثم تحصل على تجربة نوم كاملة 180 درجة. إلى الأمام لتجربته ، لم أفكر في ذلك لأنني أعلم أنك ستكون مسطحًا بغض النظر عن ذلك عندما تريد أن تقرأ أو تأكل هذا النوع من الاتكاء اللطيف فقط في الخلف ليس كل بطريقة ولكن يكفي فقط لتكون في وضعية الاسترخاء أثناء تناول الزيت ، كيف تفعل ذلك في الحمام الثابت ، سوف تكون وسائدًا ستلتف وتسبح لا لا لا لا ، هذه ليست الطريقة التي تعمل بها ، نعم أعني أولا وقبل كل شيء انها مصممة العاشق  رائع
حتى يمكنك أن تعرف ضبط
وضعك باستخدام
الوسائد ، وجمال المقعد هو أنه
لا توجد آلية لا يوجد محرك
ووزنه أقل ،
لذا فهو حل مستدام للغاية
[موسيقى
] يا له من حظ قليل في طريق عودتي من
ستوكهولم  في السويد ، حيث كنت أصور
الأسبوع الماضي ، لاحظت وجود رحلة جوية
بدون توقف من ستوكهولم إلى نيويورك
ولديها المقعد الجديد يمكنني تجربتها.
تحول إلى
سرير ،
نعم ، أعتقد أن بعض الناس يشعرون
بالارتباك وكأنهم يشبهون إذا لم تكن هناك
وظيفة استلقاء ، كيف يمكنني النوم تمامًا ،
لكنك تقول إنه يذهب إلى
مكان يذهب إليه في السرير ، نعم هذا
هو المقعد  شرنقة إذا كنت ترغب في ذلك ، ولكن
بالطبع الشيء الثوري هو أن
المقعد
لا يتكئ ،
فماذا يعني ذلك نعم ، سوف يذهب إلى
السرير بالطبع يمكنني أن أذهب بهذه الطريقة ولكن
عندما أجلس هنا فقط
مسترخياً أشاهد التلفاز
، لا يوجد زر  للذهاب
لذلك ستعمل جلستك قليلاً  أنا في الهواء
ثماني ساعات من الطيران في انتظاري ، حان الوقت
للاستلقاء للخلف ،
فماذا أفكر في جناح الصالة الجديد الرقيق الذي
أعتقد أنه بمجرد أن تتخطى الفكرة المفاهيمية
بأنها لا تتكئ ،
فهي رائعة تمامًا
هناك  هي مساحة أكبر بكثير
للراحة في العديد من المواقف المختلفة ،
إنها مشكلة لا تتكئ ، وإذا تمكنت
من التغلب على ذلك ،
فستعجبك ، فسيكون هناك بعض الأشخاص
الذين لا يمكنهم
[موسيقى]